people ask you this all the time and
i've asked you this all the time and i'm
still gonna ask you this
um obviously i love man from uncle and
just like
everybody else who's seen it um so what
do we need to do
to get more and now here's my pitch
if someone were to write some fan
fiction
or like some quasi-animated thing would
would you be willing to voice it and
then we could just
try to ask henry to do it too i mean it
i would do
another man from uncle in a heartbeat
like in a heartbeat
uh if someone wrote a really good piece
of fanfic i'd narrate it
if someone wrote an extremely good piece
of fanfic
i would make sure it got to [ __ ] guy
and lionel and be like you guys need to
read this
and then give this person co-writing
credit cause let's just get this movie
made let's just do this
look i'm all in on that i think that
movie is criminally underrated
and uh that's why i keep on bringing it
up because people need to watch it
yeah i mean it was so much fun to make
honestly it's one of the movies
i mean a part obviously from like call
me by your name it's one of the movies
that i get the most messages about
people just being like i want another
one of those what do we do